hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments
mama Mia but here I go again
oh hey Marc I know how to make holy
water put water in a pot turn on the
stove burn the hell out of it
finger guns what how tall are you for
real you're probably 27 I'm 16 years
younger than you and I'm five too if
you're shorter I'm gonna die laughing
what have you got against people that
are short are you laughing at people
that are sure what does it matter you're
16 years younger than me that means
you're
eleven you're 11 and that butan that
it's not that tall so as far as you're
concerned I'm I'm - I'm 1 foot 1 that's
how tall I am you take a ruler a
footlong ruler add an inch get a baker's
dozen of inches and ask me okay that's
me all right
mark the squirrels need their king
they're calling for you mark go to them
Tony so I'm trying to read and comment
here shut up
dance like a banana
hey Marky balls tell us another
embarrassing story the last one was
great oh I'm glad to get so much joy out
of my embarrassment well I got one for
you back in high school I had a lot of
acne and by that I mean I had a lot of
acne I had so much acne that my dad
thought it would be a good idea to
enroll me in a medical study for an
experimental treatment for acne and this
may not seem embarrassing to you but at
the time I was extremely self-conscious
about it so when you're in a medical
study you're gonna have a whole bunch of
doctors poking at your face and this is
me this is like pubescent markiplier
here I'm like 15 or something and I'm
sitting in a chair and there's all these
nurses and doctors various people poking
at my face they drew with a sharpie
straight down my nose and straight
across my face to segment my v into four
separate but like four separate segments
so that they could have one a control
segment and then three different
experimental treatments that they had
with really three weeks and it was great
on the on the ones that worked but then
I just had like this big patch of acne
on the untreated segments so they were
like oh yeah oh this isn't just you
naturally getting better well this is
our treatment well good luck here's 50
bucks [ __ ] off now
have fun with your corner acne face
to live with that for a while but I was
named I'm from Australia and I'm
currently in bed with a concussion and
super bored with the soon-to-be scar on
my forehead so please
my name is pronounced so differently
over in America love hearing different
accents love you and your videos xoxo
whoa
Jorge Jorge Alou Jorge Jorge I allow
Kure Jia Liu ji Gorgui Liu dargah Liu
Corgi Lulu Campbell ooh Gary goo
kangaroo you're from Australia kangaroo
I got it
got I get it Arco my good girl know how
to answer this oh my god
the cat wants me dead it was cat it
plotting your demise Kenny said first we
can decisive strike you board um maybe
you need to talk out your personal
problems or killing Oakley and Sookie I
don't think I want to do either of those
things Seth are you a member of the
butter gluttons my cool yet
yoku mark can you summon Satan live in
one of your videos what porn oh yeah oh
that's the good stuff
oh look at that oh you wanna put ours no
I am hey Mark you should come to Alaska
you got a lot of fans up here that would
love to see you I would love to go to
Alaska I would love just to see the
landscape and wilderness out there
because one of the things that I've
learned to appreciate a lot is America's
national park system and we have an
astonishing National Park System there's
nothing like it in the rest of the world
just in the sheer magnitude of it and
I'm not even just talking about one part
we have like hundreds hundreds and
hundreds of national preserves and parks
and Alaska is this one huge wild untamed
wilderness I mean obviously it's super
cold up there but you know not always
and I would love to go and see it and I
want to see all of the all the national
parks that the US has and then go
internationally and see all of the
wonders of the world I want to be well
traveled some because Aimee and I just
went out to Joshua Tree which is another
park and it's beautiful land mountains
and rocks and these weird trees they
call Joshua trees that apparently flower
once every 10 years it's just there's so
much to see out there and I want to
experience it all so hopefully I get an
excuse too someday
hey Mark how old were you when you had
your first kiss I can't remember if I
talked about this before my first kiss
was interesting because it was at a
who's that like sophomore year
homecoming in my high school and it was
with a girl who I had not gone there
with who had come with a friend of mine
I was there alone I was there just you
know going stag you know totally by
choice you know I didn't want to go with
the bid or anything but then when I got
there I met up with my buddy Garrett
who's there with his date and then
later on in the night let's see who
could do another and I ended up making
out with his date I do I do not
encourage that behavior it was dumb
she said they came there as friends oh
man that was does not oh my god just one
of those covers you know I'm feeling it
what do you think back in something bad
you did
really ah [ __ ] why did your that stupid
high school Daisy I'm 27 now what the
[ __ ] do I care
ah devastating my brain all I never is
oh the horror
Garrett and I are fine do you like to
crash onto folding tables it is funny
not anymore Bogey's along get in god
[Music]
earth earth he's acting listen to paying
off mark please crash on the table
I can't he dead don't you know right hey
Mark just like you have done with
YouTube I'm also starting my journey
with photography how did he keep
yourself motivated well to be perfectly
honest like motivation is fleeting
motivation is a temporary state of being
it's some people like some people get
confused by they think like to carry you
to your goals you're going to be
motivated the entire way no you're not
you're going to hit periods where things
slow down and they just turn into a slog
and it's just it's it's like it really
does become a chore no matter how much
you love something if you do it all the
time you will get tired of it but what
the real struggle is is finding it again
you have to dig deep and always be
looking back on what makes what you do
so special to you what makes it so
important remember why in the beginning
why you wanted
and that's why I'm bringing back reading
your comments and I know it's been over
a year since the last one but I'm
bringing it back just because I
remembered why they did in the first
place because it was another avenue to
interact with you guys and it was
another way to get feedback from you
guys and also another way for me to
express myself and in in the creation of
videos or in the creation of photography
like you you have to always always find
new and old ways to keep yourself
motivated and never lose sight of the
original vision that you have even if
the goal is changed the original reason
why is usually always the same unless
you need to find a new reason why but
it's a challenge it's a struggle but you
can do it mark if you don't do a flip
you'll a bad luck oh god Oh show us your
scars please all right I have a standing
desk now I gotta get I'm 9 I'm one foot
one very short there's my belly
there's my belly button here's my second
belly button from That star here's this
scar though is the straight incision
down here that's not just sweet abs
that's a nice scar makes sense cool
beans okay here's another one there's
another one there's another one oh boy
Oh could you all enjoy my Tumtum I know
I did you're brave Marc you had the
courage to play that dragon cancer for
us regardless of what you've been
through I know personally I couldn't do
that because I have too much anxiety and
stress levels it is you know I I don't
want to say I'm the bravest person in
the world for playing that game but that
game was it was pretty heavy for me but
the one thing that I think is important
to know about me is that I don't look
back at the time I don't look back at me
losing my dad as the great tragedy of my
life
I wish it were any other way like of
course it I would love to have my dad
around today but I I take that loss and
I once again I use it to keep pushing me
forward you know I I use it as
motivation to imagine what would make my
dad proud
because I remember the lessons that my
dad taught me my whole life and I
remember that he was a good dad and he
was probably the best dad I could ever
hope for
and he was just always such a good
person and so I used that to try to
emulate who he was and carry on that
spirit because I am my father's son
and just because cancer took him away
doesn't mean that he's gone from my life
and that's always important marks don't
read this Oh God
[Applause]
oh that is all the time I got for
reading your comments today thank you
everybody so much for watching I know it
has been over a year since the last
episode and I honestly didn't even know
if I was going to bring the series back
but just this past weekend I took a long
break and I was watching old videos and
I was listening to the old like music
that I had stored up and I was I was
just remembering all these cool moments
of the past and and I was remembering
also like I can just keep making them
like it doesn't have to be in the past I
can always make them in so I was reading
through the last video I did which was
the marching band one and I just I loved
every moment of it
I loved the silliness of it I loved the
the fun of it the seriousness of the
emotions of it gives me a reason to talk
to you guys and it gives me a reason to
see everything that you make unless
that's beautiful so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching I also
want to mention that we are doing a
charity livestream tomorrow tomorrow and
Thursday we will be doing new sales I
believe we have pajama pants and we have
special shirts available and also will
be doing giveaways it's spread over two
days six hours of peace so hopefully
everyone will be able to stop by and
join tomorrow 12:00 p.m. p.m. Pacific
Standard Time two six and then Thursday
at probably the same time so thank you
everybody someone for watching if you
want your comment read put it down in
the comments below or anywhere else on
the channel or even anywhere outside on
the social medias I will be checking
tumblr Twitter Facebook I want to look
all over the place for these comments so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye